when uh me too was first breaking out i
had a lot of very famous friends
freaking out
thinking i don't know what's gonna who's
gonna come forward from the hundred
girls i was with who you know just
decides that they didn't like what i did
that night four years ago and i'm
screwed and they would have been you
know and they were sweating it
so i think the future of you know a
signed contract is not that uh uh you
know not that crazy um but videos that
people have reputations sure and uh you
know it's it's disgust but by and large
all actors are crazy so you know what
you're getting into you know that's true
they were just nutty people
um myself included you know it's just
it's a weird kind of uh profession to
pursue it's
it's it's an insane profession to pursue
it's impossible the rejection is
constant so you kind of be that kind of
person who embraces rejection uh there's
got to be a lot of ego involved a lot of
ego i mean because if you're especially
if you're on camera how do i look how do
i am i perceived how does the world
perceive me